kleist birgit schmitz katzen lieben
keine fremden schon gar nicht solche mit
kamera auch nicht wenn frauchen mit
futter lockt kater fritz hat sich
versteckt und rosi verschanzt sich
hinterm ofen aber lieben die breiten
wenigstens ihre besitzerin
diese frage hat birgit schmid
umgetrieben warum eigentlich
besonders das muss nicht immer sich der
rallye und das im märz vorträge schon
ansporn und psychologisch besonders
konstituiert dass das in der liebe kampf
aber kann diese kreatur menschen lieben
ein raubtier ein nesträuber unzählige
youtube filmchen kreisen um diese
gretchenfrage der kuss tests soll
klarheit bringen
sie liebt mich sie liebt mich nicht
zähl ich mich sie liebt mich nicht auch
wenn fritz und rosi knutschen dass es
eine freude ist
birgit schmid faszination geht tiefer
ruhe natur und die bleibt für den
zivilisierten menschen immer etwas
geheimnisvoll
oft geht es um projektionen aus sind die
bilder wenn ich mitmache gar nicht
unbedingt der harz mit entsprechen also
sein knie nach einem richtungswechsel
ist erkenntnis führen weg zur sonne mit
ihr das macht 1 1 partie fähiger zwerge
so groß für all die die lager wiese
zurück zur ausgangsfrage können katzen
menschen lieben was sagt die
wissenschaft
die rennen hier die bestätigen dass hat
wenig fähig sind und dass
verschiedentlich bewiese das hat nicht
unbedingt die person
diese eigenwilligen schlingel
die ängste bindung schaffen sie durch
lecken denn damit überträgt die mutter
ihren geruch auf die kleinen das
funktioniert genauso zwischen katze und
mensch
lecken ist der ultimative liebesbeweis
dazu kommen weitere spielarten ist die
antwort klar